Майже в кожної дитини є смартфон.
10-12-річні школярі щодня користуються інтернетом
і добре на ньому знаються. Фейсбук - це вже,
так би мовити, для старшого покоління.
Я користуюсь Снапчат.
Вотсап та Ютьюб переважно.
Інстаграм.
Твіттер.
Дослідження показали, що школярам загалом
відомо про небезпеки інтернету, утім, вони
мало що знають про емоційний вплив
соціальних мереж. Експерти переймаються
передусім дітьми у віковій групі від 8 до 12 років.
Соціальні медіа, якими користуються діти,
майже неконтрольовані, і їхній вплив
непередбачуваний. Я не думаю, що діти
емоційно готові до такої комунікації в соцмережах.
Відправити фото, селфі, відео у вотсап
чи виставити в інстаграм – це наче заклик
до визнання: лайки, фоловери чи оцінки –
це єдине, що має значення.
Що класного в соцмережах?
Одні люди надихають інших.
Можна показати власний талант.
Без соцмереж треба було б писати листи,
а вони губляться.
А що поганого в соцмережах?
Погані коментарі можуть засмутити.
Іноді взагалі не хочу в школу.
Я теж.
Кібермоббінг.
Коли весь час дивишся в смартфон,
почуватимешся погано.
Як ти почуваєшся, коли користуєшся соцмедіа?
Добре і погано.
Сумно через коментарі.
Залежно від ситуації.
Дослідники інтернету часто вбачають
зв'язок у користуванні соцмережами
з одного боку та депресією чи навіть суїцидом
серед підлітків з іншого. Багато батьків та експертів
вимагають, щоб школи та й самі соцмережі
приділяли більшу увагу дослідженню впливу
на молодь.
Ми зобов’язані правильно спрямовувати дітей
у цьому процесі. Їм потрібне відчуття самоповаги,
щоб вони були не такі вразливі,
коли йдеться про лайки.
У цій берлінській школі на спеціальних уроках
говорять про емоційні переживання дітей
у соцмережах. В Англії навіть планують
інтегрувати цю тему в навчальний план.
Дедалі більше експертів єдині в тому,
що дітей не можна залишати наодинці
з викликами від соцмереж.